before the break are writer Sam we did a
whole long thing with Sam's mom trying
to find love she chose a guy with a
six-pack from Miami a realtor named
Johnny G A lot of people wrote in and
said uh how did the mom do with her date
they had a zoom date to see how that
would go I'll give away the lead right
away I don't think it was a love
connection there was like a chemistry
for one thing you spent the entire day
talking about himself uh-uh and you know
if I could advise men I'm no ladies man
okay you gotta ask a woman a couple of
questions here's a montage of Johnny G
talking about his favorite subject
Johnny G father and mom got divorced
when I was about eight and dad moved to
Miami Beach first my I had a bar mitzvah
I had like every kid that was you know
worthwhile as far as I'm concerned I
went to Camp kennybrook right I'm a very
sexual person just to be blunt I'm not
into the weird fetishes man I don't
believe in that I want to become a
sexual influencer there were more places
and let's call it Aventura in the 1980s
that were Geared for single people oh
interesting now I have a first cousin
named Kathy with a c my mother told me
later that uh well when she was pregnant
with me that it's all she ate was pizza
yikes Johnny spent seven minutes on the
topic of pizza alone
I gotta play a little bit of it for you
I can't play all seven minutes when I
left New York I was you know missing the
New York Pizza the only thing that was
even close to it but not when didn't go
by that name was Wolfgang Puck in L.A he
had the California Pizza Kitchen right
he made specialty pizzas so I wanted
real pizza so we had the whole week then
we did a calorie counted pizza oh my God
but we had like 27 toppings we had
sun-dried tomatoes smoked mozzarella
smoked provolone so I looked it up and I
found out that the number one pizza
cookbook in the world was a guy named
Pasquale Bruno Jr okay and I I just
picked up the phone and I called them
hey Kathy can you calm down so I can
hear Johnny talking about pizza would
you stop interrupting
when the date was over we asked Johnny
to give the day to grade to see if he
learned anything about Kathy give the
date a grade A Plus to F I would call it
an A plus I think for what it was it
couldn't have gone any better and your
interest in Kathy on a scale of one to
ten after this date oh I I'm
10. I'd like
is great and I know we'd have fun it's
not even a question so let me ask what
are the top three new things you learned
about Kathy during the state wow
top three it's a difficult question we
met I don't think that I learned
anything for shatteringly New how about
the top one thing you learned about
Kathy that I was right that she's
exactly what I thought she would be Sam
your daughter Kathy thinks you're really
smitten with uh Johnny G oh my really uh
she thinks you're holding back no
because he said that she she was a real
champ for putting up with the whole
thing so I think she's
Sam Sam what's the deal you know she
goes back and forth between how much she
wants me involved but at the same time
after her call with Johnny G I had three
missed calls from her she was like man
he's a great guy I really had a she was
so into it so I think she's playing it
down because maybe there's no chance
because he lives in Florida but she
seemed to be really into him in their
private conversation from my
purse with him I mean I wouldn't be
jumping into bed with him but I would
certainly not a good reason to come to
New York if uh yeah yeah what are you
gonna get on a plane
and my tip to all guys out there if
you're if you're talking to a woman on
the phone
and and for like an hour she's just
saying right and uh-huh she's probably
bored and losing interest right right
Johnny so I took uh I took off like I
was on a Runway so I don't know what the
hell I was thinking
right Johnny Kathy God bless I hope you
two kids meet up one day and and we'll
see we'll see what happens
just show your six-pack abs and don't
talk so much okay
thank you